[Music]
in that's just creepy news hmm submitted
by always on brand nurses have been
suspended after medical instruments used
on a celebrity were offered for sale
online this is the scalpel we used for
[ __ ] Ethan Hawke in our yeah this is
the catheter we put up
gene Simmons his pee hole oh that so I
would sell if you got an autograph -
that would really show lead singer of
KISS not gonna like pop into my head
when I start I think around slowly
because he's probably under - he's
probably under so you could be like yo
gene sign the show he's like what you
think they could sell the [ __ ] laser
that they are the thing that they used
to go through your dick hole yeah for
sure
not not Vermont I might buy it no the
camera when I had a kidney stone yeah
brother I've had that done TV he's just
sold kidney stone oh no I had a camera
shoved up my pee hole why cuz they found
a little blood in my urine and they
wanted to like test out what was going
on cuz they just I took like I had a
lucky girl a UTI
no no UTI - just a little blood way your
was that telling you right now and
they're like we would like to put a
camera up there to see what's going on
are you like [ __ ] no I was like no the
see what's going on like it's not a
vlogger it's the worst bro you've been
doing a [ __ ] job really so they kind of
like did they do the thing with a kind
of like I thought they clamped my [ __ ]
and kind of sent like some type of Lube
so they clamped the tip your dick they
like and they kind of did like drop some
Lube into the pee hole and then what
that's done that's what I think open it
they leave me up first but they cut I
couldn't see what was but I felt that's
what was going on oh you weren't under I
wasn't under oh [ __ ] brother I was under
I was a wave dawg and then they do this
they go okay on three tickets heat
breath and I was like alright - I know
it anyway I [ __ ] felt II give you
anything no [ __ ] monsters
were you and need to get out and then
like wait was that that were you in a
bathtub covered in ice what do they do
take pictures I was waiting on I think
not I guess with a garage it went really
well I was it wasn't a camera or was it
like a biopsy kind of I was in Tijuana
in a garage not and it was a camera and
and okay I just think about is making my
my it smack in my dick trip yeah we're
gonna give you anything man come on I
don't remember them giving me anything
and then and then for like the whole day
I was just like it burned when I pee and
I was peeing out like lube and [ __ ] yeah
that's what I would me but they went up
there with the camera oh no no it was
fine it was just it was something like
it was nothing crazy there's nothing to
be concerned about yeah I know it was
just a little blood let me just wait let
me just wait but off anything that I get
I feel weird I just wait three days
sometimes it goes away I think that's
the natural you know thing we do out
here in America yeah well they blasted
my kidney stone out and pulled it out oh
oh I see why they had to be on you gotta
be under because it was in there for a
while exactly and then they they put a
stent in me to collect all the fragments
like Jamie's dolls look crazy too good
now that should look like cauliflower
this uh so this Chinese hospital has
disciplined its staff
oh yeah after there was social media
posts about them trying to sell like the
the bag or like hey why don't you try to
take an opportunity to so this this is a
well-known Singaporean singer song
songwriter named JJ Lin hmm basketball
player
I barely know [ __ ] investments JJ Lin
he's been like very very very very few
he's like one of the top men Mandel
popular Mandopop man Ocala baby yeah so
it mandarins male singers so men who hop
star mondo ponies 38 years old he's had
13 albums since 2003 and he's performed
extensively in China
around the world so he has a huge
following among Chinese speaking
communities so after he stayed at this
hospital which there saying that he went
in to treat a fever the hospital staff
oh here's another photo of him okay
ended up taking I want that outfit the
matador outfit he looks like a character
not at or some [ __ ] yeah it looks like
some Dragon Ball Z shoes yeah with the
guys hold the blade just looks like a
shower curtain so this is like an IV bag
and I don't know what it says Bart do
you know it's cold
um it's kind of far away and backwards
okay yeah so then they also have this
video what are they doing there wait
oh is that after you have effect for
their fan club here you could have any
one of those women they're [ __ ]
drinking from his bedpan
and don't like middle-aged women - yeah
we didn't do that who wouldn't do that
like it was your favorite celeb that's
like if Brad Pitt was in the hospital he
left all the chicks would be laying on
that yeah we were picking up our
motorcycle out of that and the girl was
like oh yeah I'm gonna deliver this
Harley - um Jason Momoa and then I was
like whoa she was like in the set
Adele's Eminem's hospital bed Nikki be
[ __ ] all over that [ __ ] man
sniffing the seeds like pick every every
single cell everything that's a lot a
lot of work Jason oh we totally rub my
face on Jason Momoa his bike crotch [ __ ]
yeah after he sat on it he'll know he's
yes I wouldn't know it's like bring it
Aquaman you girl would you smell where
his butt was as well hell no well yeah
she was sitting on it naked I would lick
it real tip you guys don't see this is
the real tip of it hanging out with come
on would you looking like this no I
really
yeah yeah after a long day of riding
if Jason Momoa slid in your diems
renowned as a hey I want to ride your
face oh she would say suffocate me then
he says I think guys are always going to
have a Paul passage those girls down
[Laughter]
she's asking if we have a Hall Pass now
and then I'll say and I think most guys
are always down to have a Hall Pass if
the chick is down have it just scared to
open it up it's usually the girls that
are a little bit more sensitive about
that subject so you want to help you you
would have like would you be down to
okay so let's say let's say let's say
let's say okay we get it
let's say science that there was a Hall
Pass and Jason Momoa slitting your dams
and then who's Casey's like celebrity
crush score Joe Roseanne no he hates
wrong Jansen wonder wonder woman Javed
oh no the Waker uh [ __ ] she was in but
the leo scene which she's like this and
she's teasing Bobby shirt so if Mimoza
here it's one of each gender and and and
then and then margot robbie was in his
diems would you let him [ __ ] yeah after
I was probably suck it
yeah Jason Momoa bringing out the real
tip thank you Jason why Jason one time I
was I had to hook up with this girl in
the homey and like the homies thought
she was so fine he was like damn let me
suck your dick right now so I guess the
best residual residual [ __ ] nut the
Jews by the way thank you for watching
on patreon I think it was like [ __ ]
Kevin Hart I went on and I couldn't be
he's too clean but it was one of the
comedians was like saying like he will
smell Beyonce's fart and in [ __ ]
inhale it just to get close to her why
would he say that he can he can be close
to her like he might see her at a
[ __ ] house party awkward now right if
you're an a-lister talking about a
Lister you're gonna see them that
something he wasn't a list level
comedian oh [ __ ]
consequences a beyonce is like a a
listers a list or a list so I don't even
know if even for a Lister shoe
Illuminati Lister I mean she's like the
Oprah of [ __ ] singers and [ __ ]
exactly she's right next to Oprah yeah
I'm just trying to think of other sex
[ __ ] no I'm thinking what did Jason
Momoa was like okay my head okay what if
what if he was like yo I'm down to smash
but it has to be of course you'd be down
for that I was gonna say but your your
man has to join us so it's like a
threesome he wants to have sex with
Casey do not even be down if his wife
joined why she is beautiful yeah I
forgot her name even as stepdaughters
gorges of course of course
oh yeah I read down for her to join she
looks really good oh yeah of course
mmm Oh name sacrificing Casey if he
wants to [ __ ] Casey that's not a
sacrifice to Casey oh it is a sacrifice
yeah you'd be sacrificing a sport was a
guy I think you just leased up a name
and it's a big guy it's a [ __ ] man's
man he's like whoa Casey's
it's gonna braid it like a big
[ __ ] are you massive in every
way in every way like he's thick he's
starting he's tall we thought we thought
about his dick first and then his rest
of his body I didn't think it was thick
at all actually dude even now with his
dad budget bill does have a dad bob was
like [ __ ] he doesn't have one but the
media you know how they just find one
picture of him exhaling ones like yeah
that's annoying he's dated Jersey Mike's
up and they're like oh yeah Tim who's
your Hall Pass um it for long Sami was
stacey dash from clueless because I saw
the huge crush on her but then she got
all weird she's still hot though she's
still my movies at fitting she's [ __ ]
hot what what why is she crazy one
degree I hope that's true right how does
she get crazy
she just got I mean I don't know she got
crazy she just as she got older she's
not as hot as like you know clueless
days of course those days were hot huh
she's still a mill for sure yeah for
sure I mean I'm down for the mill you
don't know you know my whole house would
probably be I got a maybe some gal gadot
McHale Godot or what's-her-face from the
from the Pussycat Dolls Nicole
Scherzinger oh no I know but I like that
though how would if I was a doing I
always say JLo cause no matter what gala
still looks good she's forever [ __ ]
fine
JLo still bomb yeah but she looks good -
oh hi Barry oh yeah John wick three JLo
does what she was not like I I want I
want Selena JLo no no I want I want a
new stripper movie JLo I'm down I'm down
with it you know
caught me off guard we watch Flintstones
how the pedal is really hard with me
that was her that would tell you yeah
I honestly think she got even hotter as
she aged yeah yeah what about her now
then Flintstones was it double-oh-seven
or mission impossible we should show the
boobs sorry face or monster's ball
muscles ball for sure she was not Hut
what did you see the sex scene
she got rekt Mazda sure he actually had
sex with her I've literally only seen
this egg zine oh yeah I mean that's not
her like most feminine role well she had
her short hair there I hope I've only
seen the sexy in it is fire this whole
thing was about
okay Jason Momoa go fight in our DNA
[Music]
[Music]